gib mir drei sterne bitte da sind die
sollstärke bin ich laut scho wieder a
löw meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer schau mal hier
ich habe mir übrigens so eine hülle für
mein ipad gekauft damit ich hier sowie
[ __ ] [ __ ] was soll ich denn jetzt wieder
gemacht hier einfach damit nicht immer
wenn ich das irgendwie das ist da das
ist dann nicht direkt kaputt geht aber
ich würde sagen wir herzlich willkommen
hier zu riskieren wird es von einem
kumpel namens johannes empfohlen dass
ich mal riskieren zocken soll weil das
irgendwie ganz cool sein soll also ich
würd sagen wir klicken mal auf tab to
play und fliegen los samstag ein spiel
seelische level 148 das erinnert mich so
ein bisschen an hieß er noch dieses game
suki copter dieses spiel von dem flirt
mache auch na ja jedenfalls zog ich
drücke einmal ach ich muss gedrückt
halten ihr ok ich muss machen muss ich
dann irgendwie abholen oder so
anscheinend habe ich wieder irgendwas
falsch gemacht im gestorben das ist voll
auf den kampf an
kein ding teil 65 nur ein stern level 2
okay let's go ich glaube ich hab das
spielprinzip schon relativ normal
verstanden hier was ist rein theoretisch
wenn ich hier drauf landes
das ist eine alternative auf jeden fall
okay ich mache es einfach so wie das
spiel will ich hier drum rum dann fliege
ich vielleicht hier aus lang oder so
dann ganz easy luca keinen baum berührt
nichts machen einfach hier und wieso nur
zwei sterne
hallo kate upton
es ist so unfassbar dieses spiel ist
eigentlich so schlecht oder gamer vor
canaria von ihm gespielt aber ich spiele
so was gar nicht aber das einfach das
vorlauf für so gaming ich bin tot meint
ja das auch schon für gta iv macht oder
ob du wirst du deshalb schwarz ich
nämlich nicht
wir nehmen natürlich alle mit wir sind
ein multikultureller helikopter und dann
packen raus magath ja back on the table
habe ich jetzt mal endlich freunde
sonnig war als ob ich nie drei sterne
bekomme ich war doch so fucking schnell
unterwegs ja immer vorn ein die werbung
ist nicht interessant weil kate upton da
nicht mit drin war immer meine bilder
jetzt richtig scheiße ich will einfach
mal drei sterne linie mitnehmen dann
fliegen wir jetzt hier runter nehmen ihm
natürlich noch mit dann gehen wir hin
nehmen wir den rotschopf noch mit
everyone von dem altar der typ
blitzschneller der helikopter wenn ich
die ganz auf mein gott jetzt ganz ganz
schnell wenn ich die ganze zeit gedrückt
halte
gib mir dein sterne bitte da sich die
leuchte habe wow bin ich laut schon
wieder ist zwei uhr in wittlich und ihr
morgen und ich bin 100 grad wie so
richtig sowie felix als ob da oben auch
noch flugzeuge lang fliegen man die
krank ist das denn hier auf einmal
aufnehmen als ersten cd rom ischl mit da
nehmen wir den kollegen hier mit dann
nehmen wir den hier irgendwie das ist
auch total unnötig stehen einfach auf
solche berggipfeln und warten darauf
dass der helikopter die ab juli ich
glaube an dich jetzt hier schnell zurück
ich hör auf mit youtube ich mal nur noch
bei solchen meisterschaften von diesem
spiel hin soll nämlich überhaupt auf ok
anscheinend müsste alles laufen
ich hoffe wenn ihr diese szene gerade
seht dann hab ich aufgehört ob sie so
viele level in more levels cummings
lokals und was soll ich denn hier
gesehen jetzt ein endlos modus machen
wir mal kurz den end des modus rescue as
many as you can ok oh gott ja ein das
ist auf jeden fall richtig neu ist auch
das ist dann so wie doodle jump sohn
etwa das dann von unten so also wenn du
glück haben kommt natürlich kein wasser
von unten aber das hat auch so dass die
die ganze zeit man muss halt so schnell
wie möglich
ich mache normal die level weiter ich
würde so gern mal höheres level spielen
um zu sehen wie das dahin als ob drei da
oben sind wie soll ich das denn packen
zum glück bin ich der king und habe gar
kein problem damit euch alle von bergen
abzuholen weil ihr auf irgendwelchen
wandertouren wird oder was weiß ich so
zwei sterne
ich war unfassbar schnell
gut jetzt habe ich auch gelernt dass ich
da oben nicht level 6 titan kätzchen
diese ja putzig werke luca nicht gegen
den masten da rumfliegen als ob ich da
auch nicht gegen darf ich das in einem
packenden pokal freuen ich weiß gar
nicht was passiert ist uns war es bei
mir alles abgestürzt ich bin nämlich
gerade level 8 weil ich mir bei der
sieben so eine werbung angeschaut habt
kann auch sein dass ihr das noch gesehen
hab ich denke allerdings eher nicht weil
irgendwie mit elgato aufzunehmen ist ein
totales reinstes chaos wirklich mit nach
mit einer ipad das geht echt gar nicht
lass mich in ruhe game of war ich will
nur zocken das ist mein verdient denn
ich werde jetzt das level schafen im
wenn nicht singe habe ich das glück dass
ich das level schaffe
warum hängst du an seiner fucking gondel
ran.de gab um einen kunden nein als ob
das ist doch nicht war die taktik ich
hole sie hier so abgeht ganz schnell
runter damit ich natürlich auch wieder
schön einen highscore am ketten bin dann
fliege ich hier eben schnell runter
holen sie hier ab jetzt diese komische
fratze da oben die da an dem ding hängt
jetzt dich hier unten
mein gott jetzt nur zurück nur zurück
luca just have to go back to be control
point mein gott dem skills
wahrscheinlich mittag wieder nicht auf
und ihr seht einfach gerade nicht das
wäre natürlich auch wieder super jetzt
haben wir ein japanisches mädchen der
gamer vor werbung
ich möchte aber okay
mein gott freuen ich bin dazu am
verzweifeln an diesem level nach
zum glück kann man schneiden das ist auf
jeden fall schon mal was weiß ich die
filter versucht hier gerade das ganze zu
schaffen so und diese taktik hier wird
mich jetzt hoffentlich zum glück führen
und zwar diese beiden da oben abzuholen
das ist so vergeht schnell das geht
nicht schaut euch das an jetzt hole ich
als erstes den coolen typen mit der keb
ab jetzt sie und es ist unfassbar diese
beiden da oben kann man nicht abholen
ohne dass man irgendwie dabei verreckt
es geht nicht man es ist nicht möglich
vor jeff m power socket da hatten wir
auch schon so unsere ein oder andere
begegnung mit dem spiegel
irgendwie ist das ganze so ein bisschen
auf den kopf oder oder kommt man jetzt
jetzt kann ich sie auf einmal kind mehr
ist ein neues kommen freunde noch einmal
hier fürs ende den endless mode da
schauen wir mal eben gut das war einst
das lassen war glaube ich da mal lieber
als versucht schauen wir noch einmal
hier wie gut ich bin damit man sich da
vergleichen kann jetzt sehe ich wieder
die kommentare höhe entlastet habe ich
17.300 allen trösel ich denke bei diesem
spiel natürlich nur an die menschen ich
bin jemand der unbedingt menschen retten
muss retten möchte auch in diesem spiel
mir geht es nicht darum dass da
irgendein highscore hat oder so ich
möchte einfach nur den menschen
erfolgten fluten möchte nur den menschen
gefallen schon die sind irgendwie auf
diese berge in der luft schwebend auf
kleinen waffel brötchen drauf geklettert
und die möchten natürlich einfach retten
das war schon immer mein leben jetzt
auf einmal eine rakete was wollen die
denn auf ankommende rakete von oben um
mein gott freunde
naja okay es war schon heiß genug sein
dann würde ich sagen meine lieben
freunde tut mir leid dass das ganze mit
einem spiel auf einmal irgendwie
abgestürzt ist aber das liegt einfach an
der kasse oder an vatikan oder an mir
ich war vielleicht nicht doch mir wenn
es euch gefallen hat will ich mich
definitiv über eine bewertung oder ein
abo oder was weiß ich freuen in der
beschreibung findet meiner sozialen
netzwerke meine kräfte weiter und dann
sehen wir uns in der nächsten folge
könnt ihr gerne spieler die spielen soll
in die kommentare schreiben